la vida Lima lista para la gran
manifestación nacional autobuses de todo
Perú han llegado a la capital
procedentes incluso de juliaca donde
murieron 19 personas en la jornada más
Sangrienta de las protestas otros no
vamos a olvidar que tanto dolor que no
se ha dejado los policías en el pueblo
juliaca así lucen los albergues con
Campesinos de todo el país en protesta
contra el gobierno de Dina boluarte más
de 30 horas de viaje Vamos a
organizarnos ya para el recorrido que
vamos a realizar con una movilización
pacífica como he indicado una protesta
transversal donde también participan
estudiantes Esta es la Universidad
Nacional mayor de San Marcos la más
antigua de Sudamérica como estudiantes
no estamos cerrando el diálogo momento y
más bien empezamos a que la rectora
pueda acceder a este diálogo y que se
puede dar una coordinación de manera
democrática que no se siga reprimiendo
asesinando más a nuestro pueblo no el
gobierno de Dina boluarte insiste en que
quieren avanzar en el diálogo y deja en
manos del Ministerio Público Las
investigaciones el ministro de finanzas
Álex Contreras dijo que las protestas se
están moderando las pretensiones de
algunos grupos que querían por ejemplo
la renuncia el cierre del Congreso la
asamblea Constituyente se están se están
moderando
pero para el analista Joan Lara la
situación responde a cuestiones
estructurales hay un proceso continuo de
tensiones no resueltas hay un elemento
muy fuerte de desigualdad económica que
se traduce en términos también
desigualdad social política cultural de
todo tipo las protestas se extienden
desde el ocho de diciembre tras el
intento de disolver el congreso del
expresidente Pedro Castillo que terminó
siendo detenido acusado de darse un
autogolpe de estado de vacancia y